how are you in mcallen because it's the
last time yes recommend it strongly
enough it's wonderful people give you
parties and and unsend you cards and
presents and and come and see you in the
city and having a lovely time and was it
wise they gave you a surprise party as a
sea yes I think they were a little bit
frightened I might have a heart attack
it was the most blissful sing and what
was nice was your party was kind of back
in your old something ground yes it was
my old school balsam school where I was
brought up and it was the day before my
birth and I thought I was just going out
for an Indian meal actually and I was
having I did have an Indian meal but it
was at school with a 150 people some of
them some had flown in from LA and no it
wasn't you didn't remember working
I wasn't enchanted than this so you
can't blame me I was invited I know and
I do remember working with you yeah
somebody made an extraordinary cake oh
they did yes it was so extraordinary
that I couldn't there to cut it and if
only you could see it you would
understand why well we can see some of
it yes because so it was you at essentia
the cake it was a likeness of me but
people at the body
well I cut into it was a sort of a
Buster on a plinth and I cut through the
pins but I mean I couldn't offer someone
an ear or a nose this this but I'm
keeping you just come from my fridge
it's a likeness but I wouldn't got it
flattering what seemed to me is it's not
really like me but it's like a character
that I might play do you think yeah I
think I could play that yeah do you not
yes but you can t eat have you been
nibbling at no one once all that down
your suit is it refrigerated yes
we have it all set for justice this is
lovely so one of your old x-men he made
a fuss about your birthday Oh what's
people sent messages and they were
invited to do that and I wonder suddenly
we've got a cake and we're all together
[Applause]
yes are you good to tell this story tell
it yeah well I just saw the end result
suddenly onto the screen at my old
school I saw Hugh Jackman and 30,000
people and he was playing in Manchester
I was just 8 miles away in Bolton and
they all sang happy birthday this is
singing happy birthday to you with all
these people
[Applause]
[Music]